the white house openly mocking americans
concerns about exploding crime and even
dismissing how the five covers it
on fox is janine pirro talking about
soft on crime consequences i mean what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe what i was
speaking to was a chiron on fox news
since you raised it which suggested this
administration is soft on crime with no
basis in the american rescue plan there
was additional funding to support local
cops programs something that every
single republican voted against but
earth to the biden white house the crime
wave ripping across the country is very
real and these stats don't lie homicides
in major american cities
are up 44
compared to two years ago
and big part of the problem are the
radical policies of the liberal da's
across the country which allow a
revolving door of violent felons back to
the streets to harm again
so far bidens refused to even talk about
it let alone condemn them
and on his brand new show cross country
lawrence jones interviewing one deputy
d.a calling out his boss
la district attorney george gascom
i guess my big question is is he
upholding
state and federal law right now no
absolutely not
our district attorney is nullifying
important laws and he's doing it
explicitly and unapologetically he's not
charging special circumstances he's not
charging gun allegations he's not
charging gang allegations he eviscerated
the
gang unit that we had to suppress gang
crime
because he wants to see fewer people go
to jail in prison
saki called you out
judge pirro anything you want to tell
the press secretary right now well i you
know she wants to know why i'm talking
about the consequences of soft on crime
well i'm talking about the consequences
of the democrat liberal progressive
leftist soft on crime criminal loving
victim-hating group that has made a
decision that no bail no jail and that
criminals are are that should be
privileged and that social justice and
rogue prosecutors should not be a part
of the criminal justice system jen are
you so locked up in your ivory tower
that you have no idea what americans
really care about and what they're
concerned about the truth is that the
killing of innocents who didn't deserve
it they didn't ask for it they did
nothing but get in the way of a murderer
very often out on your bail policies and
that murderer and not god decides that
they should die and now you and your elk
refuse to even recognize what you've
done just as we mentioned the crime way
from 2019 to 2021 is 44 percent up in
terms of homicides in major american
cities but joe biden ignored all this
joe biden ignored the looting the
burning the rioting and he ignored the
burning of a federal courthouse and
police precincts and now now he wants to
come to new york he wants to come to new
york because he wants to give funding to
local cops well why didn't he do that
when they were defunding demoralizing
and denigrating cops why now could it be
because this is an election year a
midterm year and why not increase
funding when cops really needed it you
people don't stand up for law and order
we do and you ought to think about one
thing you ought to think about the fact
that fox quadruples all the pals all of
those networks that you identified that
were talking about important things that
i wasn't here's the bottom line we
quadruple them because we talk about
things that americans care about and
maybe you and your friends ought to take
a temperature of what americans care
about and talk about it yeah herodotus
all
right
right right right yeah you order them
you take that jansaki
that is a cheap tactic though you take
the four screens of the cables and cnbc
and you say ah they're looking at this
but they're looking at that i mean that
is so low browed i mean for the white
house press secretary to pull that move
i mean that's like a twitter move right
there well the sad thing is that she's
making a media story out of something
that's much more substantive here we
have people dying with murders on the
increase in a way that causes great
great disquiet in this country there is
the cops are demoralized from coast to
coast they are demoralized i think in
some ways the bitter irony is that the
deaths of officers or detective rivera
and mora refocus people on cops in the
job they do it kind of sobered people up
oh my god what have i been thinking
about as the precincts burned and as uh
you know the other government buildings
were trashed i really do believe that
maybe this is a turning point i think
that biden coming here rather than
mocking it let him come let him get the
vibe from the nypd like could it be that
as with de blasio the cops would turn
their backs on the president of the
united states i hope it doesn't come to
that i'm i i really i i urge you
not to do it i want you to be gracious
to him
not that i'm talking i'm not lecturing
you but you know what i mean he is the
president of the united states so let
him come let him hear you let him hear
you that we can't you cannot have a
criminal justice system that does not
prosecute with special circumstances if
there are two criminals go into a
building one is a gang member and the
other isn't one has a gun and the other
doesn't those are different crimes we
have to recognize that we have to
understand that we have to punish
commensurate with the with the duty to
make the streets safer that is the
biggest most important job of government
is keeping the citizens safe dana so
she's pointing at these screens in one
of the screens says the ukraine russia
situation not a single american has died
there yet but right now in los angeles
here's a mother who spoke to lawrence
jones over the weekend guy get let out
on bail by the d.a over there shot her
daughter about 22 times listen
i started running
towards you know screaming her name i
just saw my my daughter
with a lot of blood
i started giving her cpr she's not
getting a second chance
she's not
why should he did they call you to let
you know
that they were gonna put him back out
on the street
no call
no
no call i mean i found out by the news
that was another soros funded d.a in
houston uh we actually this reminds me
of a story we just did on friday on
america's newsroom in oregon a young
woman whose father was murdered is about
to get apart the murderer is about to
get a pardon from the governor and the
reason that the victim's uh daughter
found out about it was basically through
like not through the governor's office
calling but it was through somebody in
the da's office going i don't think this
is right and then leaking it to her so
this is happening everywhere and it
could have just as easily been
my i could have been the one talking
when jen's hockey looked up right
because we talk about this a lot and you
don't get to 81 percent of americans
saying they are concerned about crime
just because people are watching fox
that act that doesn't happen and if you
saw what happened on friday with the
turnout here in
new york with for the funeral yeah
that was such a moment
and it's not about the funding
funding is great i'm every police
officer
officers department would love to have
more funding but it's not about that
it's about the policies and the
democrats i think the thing that they're
missing is that they are absolutely
linked to these progressive das and
people are starting to put it together
because you heard that young widow
on friday
in her closing statement she said i hope
that the new district attorney is
listening to you through me and she
named him so
everybody is putting this together it's
not just on on fox news it's also
happening at the border patrol it's the
same and it's the same issue right
you're not allowing us to do our jobs
and fulfill our commitment that we have
sworn to america great gut phil
well one thing i noticed about the sake
stuff is some because i'm an expert in
sarcasm when you don't have an answer
and you know that you're wrong
you use sarcasm because that is how you
do you go stop it i mean she basically
was a tweet her response was a tweet to
actual facts so she did it sarcastically
it's weird because we we live in a free
country with free speech
we feel like we we know and we see
everything
even including with our own eyes we will
see things and people will meet you with
sarcasm it's really kind of a new thing
like you talk about the crime stats
they laugh you talk about stories about
the mother whose child is killed they
laugh they say oh i went out and had
dinner that's what they said on cnn last
year even when you show the border
visuals
like in a totally different issue
they
choose to ignore it gavin newsom not
wearing a mask all of these things rely
on the fact that even though you see it
with your own eyes you can't get any
traction and why can't you get any
traction because the so-called free
speech the free press they don't do crap
about it that's their side so we can sit
here in our bubble and talk about this
forever and she could sit in her tiny
bubble and laugh at it and then what
they do is the trick is they turn left
wing politics into context there are
only three variables in that equation
about the widow
felon out on bond victim murder that's
the three variables but then what you do
is you layer on the context right cash
bail is proof of inequality but you only
rich people can afford bail so it's
wrong long sentences discriminate covid
is inhumane in prisons we've got to let
him out overcrowding is inhumane so what
that does is that clear it creates this
so-called context context when it's
actually just political ideology and
then that allows these felons to get out
and the intellectual talking heads
suddenly like gensake forget about these
variables they forget about the victim
they forget about the fiend out on bail
because they're so drowned in their
context their fake context it's just
political bs and it's probably the
largest cover your ass strategy because
both the politicians and the media know
that they were responsible for this new
pro-crime climate and this is their only
way out
all right jen saki i hope you're
watching
call me
up next president biden's plans for the
supreme court getting a supreme
smackdown from the american people hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else